well I feel kind of bad for Carmichael
but at least we can get a segment Sam
and Nico out of it morning if you don't
like blood or anything like that skip
forward lunch where do you want to go
you want to get some burgers waiting
like in and out yeah okay so it's going
to take us about 20 minutes to get there
oh it's 3.2 miles we should be able just
barely make it this will go like six and
a half miles
that will go six or seven miles
depending on how fast you go if you're
going fast you'll get less range
so pace the hill won't be an issue for
the battery yeah and the days of battery
passivity and going up the hill
spencer supposedly took his car and
there he is waiting for us he apparently
he's been wishing around the halfway
point for 5-10 minutes pulled over to
wait for Ren
kind of a little fast for him 1 mile
isn't as fast as booster board there he
is
look at him he's just a little little
little guy
enemy rings how do they do it
train tracks are hard to go over because
the wheels are gonna slip in between
here and I'll stop you dead you have to
hit it at an angle to be able to get
across a diagonal angle yes I made it a
little bit but then I fell off yeah
tonight you put in to stick to the gum
metaphor yeah I'm gonna fix that later
at least full of train tracks not being
used anymore Nick you're a historian
what why are there so many train tracks
cuz of trains with the train tracks can
I go
[Music]
it
hey you're a while you finally caught up
in and out what's the battery levels hat
for the chords to the board on so when
we left on the trip we're at 100% so now
the one wheels at 49% cheese the name of
that longboard is not working on the app
okay that sucks I have no idea what the
battery charges it says zero percent it
should be about halfway it's probably a
little bit more than halfway
unfortunately you might have told we
didn't get a shot yeah just don't take a
wrong turn you should be fine yeah
Carmichael wait elite missus screaming I
have a massive doubts about this yeah
ready
ten percent battery later man I wish
these batteries were bigger
I'm strong in the battery guess who's
pulling up right now me Oh Spencer
wait were you guys going guys we'll go
now the board dad I got a hang on
dispenser sniffing you should have be
recording video you're driving so boost
board died hey police Spencer was right
behind me
I just finished locked I come by I see
them Carmichael died right my battery
dies just when he's coming by us Wren is
still going strong
so here we are at lifeline auditions the
very first lifeline additions we were
having I hope you find some good actress
auditions are the weirdest part about
making movies because you sit there and
you judge people who drove all the way
out just to perform in front of you for
ten minutes and then you send them home
and you don't call back most of them so
anyways let's go do it
I almost died you should and now it's
Travis Collins
weird mouthing just deep first day of
auditions complete this is actually one
of the better audition sessions we've
ever had
you just sit on a couch you just listen
to your heart you listen to your gut and
if you liked watching the person and
they were interesting then great and if
you didn't then there you go your
decision is made being an actor in LA
it's got to be so tough having testing
well there's not only thousands of other
actors in that way all of mine for the
same job
even if someone actually likes your
little headshot there's still the the
callbacks which is what we just did
where the actor will then be called back
because we've expressed interest in
meeting them but they don't have a lot
of time usually they would have only 15
minutes they have 15 minutes to impress
our socks off but obviously there's a
lot of training that goes into good
acting but to [ __ ] Duchenne stop
hitting the brake so hard so all I'm
saying is at the end of the day finding
good actors is actually incredibly easy
was I entertained was that not
entertaining did you fall asleep while
you were watching them if you did and
they're probably not a great actor oh
yeah
I was in the office all day I've already
went out for one long board ride and now
I just need to go a second and what have
you done to me and you get my own boots
board now I'm not going anywhere in
particular I just spot nearby the studio
they're like practice
Carmichael are you doing hey I was going
top speed on the highest level and I
went over I went around a turn and went
over train tracks and I biffed it
thankfully my face didn't eat the ground
morning blood I pulled a rock out of my
hand at the sink Rock about that big to
join the Road Rash Club mine's almost
healed
oh and then this is not that bad but now
a Shinto down there it's a little deep
like there's a hole in my shirt my
favorite shirt there's a hole now yeah
bad choices make good stories yeah rip
muscle tissue coming out of my hand
Brad look what you did I'm gonna stick
it right back in the hole and just
pretend it's out there somebody might go
to the doctor soon this is the hole
where the rock came through this wasn't
that bad it's like a baby Wolverine cold
skin up my arm their butt
[Music]
so you sure you still want to do this
yep good that is awesome let's do that
cuz a train
cuz I'm training
come trade I can't do it until one more
net
[Music]